they can be a condor definitely pie with
ice cream definitely Beach Ocean Beach I
I have to take both both at their best
there's nothing like it picking one of
the others like picking one of your
children son oh my gosh kind of question
is that I would want to visit the
Himalayan mountain range and whatever
countries that happen to touch so be it
purple royal purple
we need more purple in the world I'm
tired of apples and oranges
I'm all for oranges so I'll take a good
orange and a good fresh-squeezed orange
juice with pulp leaving all the pulp but
effect add extra pulp and I'm there for
it salty I like potato chips popcorn
with too much salt on it salt stupid
question the stargazer lily of course
it's beautiful
our days are Lily they're chess piece I
like the rook over there in the corner
comes out when you need it Pegasus who
needs a stick coming out of your head
you want to be able to fly definitely
lemonade but it's got to be good
lemonade none of this powder mix lemon
flavored go get in the back and squeeze
some lemons put in some sugar and I'm
good for you I'm not in denial of the
impact and significance of the Harry
Potter series but in terms of the weight
the the social cultural philosophical
literary weight of the Lord of the Rings
I had edges that edges out
part for me never sleep with socks on
I'd like a neato freedom under the
covers at all-time Saturn totally Saturn
is cool because it's like it's less
dense than water so sanity I found a
lake big enough savages float definitely
going the Sheep I think they're more
useful to us I know that's bad for the
Sheep I'm just saying just being honest
in the shower because we all sound
awesome in the shower I try to sing
songs where the deep voice matters go
down bosu you know
swing swing low and I can't keep up dude
let's go on a shower we could do this
right manopoly all the way we think
about how much you learn about our
American capitalist society by mastering
monopolies a cumulonimbus cloud there's
a lot of action in a cumulonimbus cloud
and that totally the cloud I would be I
make a pretty good french toast so I
will take my french toast over anybody's
french toast I have ever tasted it but
there's nothing like a good buttermilk